now there are two cities of Buenos Aires
one behind these fences for the g20
leaders and one on this side for
everyone else and it does make sense
because those who are attending are the
most powerful people in this world these
are really the ones that are making our
planet spin
[Music]
well the folks from that boy know sadhus
have recently made us realize that we
are indeed living in a multipolar world
where everyone's holding on to their
national interests and that ahead of the
summit has led to a whole lot of
problems between those who've been
saying my country first Donald Trump's
lately been after China all the time
he has blamed Beijing for stealing
technology unfair trade and even
meddling in the u.s. midterms
regrettably we found that China has been
attempting to interfere in our upcoming
2018 election against my administration
because I am the first president ever to
challenge China on trade Beijing has
been much more careful with what they're
saying but they're giving out warnings
to in the last century we had two world
wars and in between them the Great
Depression I don't think anybody should
really try to have a repetition of
history these things should never happen
again so people have to act in a
responsible way the brutal murder of
journalist Jamal kesaji has been taken
install on how the rest of the world's
been dealing with Saudi Arabia's
Mohammed bin Salman by the way has been
in bone assadís since Wednesday wouldn't
look at the monstrosity that happened in
the Saudi Arabian consulate in Turkey it
must be cleared up as long as it's not
cleared up there will be no arms exports
to Saudi Arabia I can assure you of that
[Music]
someone else angle a Merkel's not a big
fan of is US President Donald Trump
along with one of her best European
buddies Emmanuel macron they're trying
to push for a European army and Donald
Trump really hates that idea now mr.
macron who's really been trying to make
an effort to become close friends with
mr. Trump it seems is beginning to have
tschüss was the US administration truth
said some of trumps recent decisions
have been done to the detriment of
allies these fundamentally overturns the
legal basis for friendly ties between
Japan and South Korea and is extremely
regrettable that was what Tokyo had to
say on South Korea's Supreme Court
verdict ordering a Japanese firm to pay
compensation to Koreans for forced labor
during World War two and as you heard
that ruling could be enough to reignite
old hostilities between the countries
[Music]
the UK's painful divorce from Europe
might lead to a few awkward moments for
Teresa May and Buenos Aires the Prime
Minister will be looking for new friends
at the summit and she's convinced other
countries will feel the same way we
might as well bear all of that in mind
when we see team g20 getting together
for the family photo perhaps some of
those smiles will have to be faked
you